If you find your stitch
symbols palette, empty it's
because somehow the font file
that displays the symbols on the screen
has gotten erased or
corrupted on your computer.
There's an easy fix.
Go from this to this.
First, download this file to a folder
on your computer where it
will be easy to to find.
You can just stick it on your
desktop if you'd like.
Once it's installed, you can
erase it from your desktop.
2. Go to your Windows
search box and type FONTS.
3. A listing of the fonts
on your machine will display.
4. Drag the file that you downloaded
and drop it into that fonts folder.
5. Close DesignaKnit and any other
Windows you have open
and restart your computer.
When you open DesignaKnit,
the fonts will be correctly
displayed and you'll be good to go.